Today's topic part two of Doja cat. Why do we, why do we do a part two?
Because she was on live and she was giving out her apology and then she name
dropped us and, uh, basically debunked what we said.
So we're gonna take a listen to her live and we'll give her thoughts and we'll
see if we're gonna have to retract anything that we said.
Maybe, maybe. So, just to give you guys a little bit of context,
we made a video about her in the past. By a couple days ago, during a tiny chat,
a chat room, she was participating in, she made, um, some comments I'll,
I'll play the clip and we made a response video to that as she goes through all
her points in her apology,
I'll bring up exactly what she did that she is addressing.
Uh, um, the next thing is race play.
So I watched a YouTube video by Abba and preach.
How was that?
You know, it very, um,
interesting people. Uh they're.
They can be very smart in a lot of, in a lot of subjects. And I,
Sam.
You, she watches a lot of videos. <laugh> oh, wow.
They could be smart in a lot of subjects, but in other ones about the same,
we could be dumbest. You didn't know. Yeah. You, when you get,
cause you problematic too, when you get square on your feet,
<laugh> I'm done with this video. I'm oh, oh.
You spread that excuse. What is that? It's per <laugh>
sorry, man. It's per it's just it's. This is the thing you've ever done.
You literally squirted on my leg and the bottle led did. Yeah.
I've never had a man do.
You going to be in the do and not tell me and I'll pass you the do yeah.
Is that gay? Yeah. No, it's not you in, you got sugary. Yeah.
You got some on your sugar. Yeah. You like sugar.
Don't that's why you like what's up easy bake oven. It <laugh> easy bake.
We gonna move on you mad, man. Anyways, she's about to say I enjoyed a few.
Videos by them. Um, but <laugh>.
But, but let's hear it. Let's hear it. There.
Was a video about me that came out a few hours ago.
I don't think it's been a day,
but the video came out was about me and it,
they, they misinterpreted what I said in a clip on tiny Chad.
So the clip that you see me where I was and yes,
this is me.
100% excusing my dumb behavior.
I'm dumb, but I'm also drunk.
I'm glad I was right about her being dumb take. I'm not expecting a young, rich,
dumb person to make smart decisions. All right. I did say that in the video,
it was a dumb thing to do now, is she right?
That we mischaracterize what she said. She is a hundred percent. Uh,
is she right? That, that wasn't race play. I don't know.
I'll take her word for it.
I can't tell her what she was feeling or what she does behind closed doors.
This was just my assessment of what I saw her.
She's saying it's not that I'm not into that. Okay. I,
I will believe you and I will retract that and I will apologize if I disparaged,
however again, but yeah, go ahead. I'm sorry. However,
your substitute for why it was when you took my reasoning out and you said it
was because I was drunk that's to me, that's not defense.
Thank you very much. Okay. Here's the thing. Thank you.
I've been arou a lot of black people when they're drunk. A lot of black people,
I have never heard the N word with a heart, ER,
come out of their mouth while they're drunk to me.
And this is my opinion about people general, when they're drunk,
how you behave when you are drunk, says something about who you are.
Even when you're sober.
I have been blackout drunk so many times in my life and there's so many
behaviors I would never think to engage with. Exactly.
So when I see people acting a fool or doing things and like I was drunk, no, no,
boo, you got stuff inside. That's repressed or something's going on.
Whether you want admit it or not. That's your choice.
If you problematic when you're drunk, you're problematic. So I'm sorry.
Go ahead. So no, that's a great point.
And that's pretty much I wanted to get at. I, I don't,
I don't think if it's for what I'm saying is wrong,
then I'll take that and we'll substitute with whatever you've got.
It doesn't necessarily make the situation that much better to me,
but I understand that your fans may see it differently and I that's fine.
I just wanted to address that point.
I can be concise. I can be clear. I can speak. I know how to speak.
I'm very, I, I am smart,
but I'm also kind of a in this video.
I'm being completely blackout, drunk and completely dumb.
Shout out to you for that. Like, like, like, I don't know.
A lot of people that would admit that they're dumb,
but she's also really smart and concise. It's kind of confusing.
<laugh> but it makes sense. You know, what's more confusing.
What a black person saying the N word on live
a black person saying that. Yeah. A black person saying that to someone else.
And yet that context that's right. Well, let's, let's keep watching. Let's keep.
Watching. I'm in no way into race play. It's not something that.
Man I gave you the best out. Let's hold on. Let me just say, go ahead.
I pretty much like your lawyer, I gave you the out, you needed to say, yo,
listen behind closed doors. I'm freak. And it's part of the brand,
but you know what you want to,
I'm assuming go for the truth or something you think is better. And I,
and listen, I will commend you on that, but I'm just saying you could hire me.
You know what I'm saying? You need a publicist. I, I flipped it for you girl,
but <laugh> I flipped it for you, girl. I don't even like you,
but I flipped it for you like a.
Burger Abbot and preach who made this video? Uh,
I think it was preach that knows Pete people who, uh, are into race play.
No, no.
It's Abba. Okay. First off, Abba. I mad at you. Okay.
Ahan Ahan and I don't know people. I just happen to stumble upon some video.
Ooh, you freaky. Ooh. You know, people that go that raise and then,
you know, you know, people that on you stupid <laugh> freak.
You're stupid. You freaky. I can't even use that word,
but it is all this to say, I don't know people. I just stumbled upon videos.
And then I discovered that that was a world. So I just want to clear that up.
And two in my defense,
I've shown this to a couple of people who work in that industry who provide
those services mm-hmm <affirmative> and they told me, yeah,
that kind of looks like it. That being said, she says, it's not.
So we do have to take her word for it.
And that's the under the comments of the video. There's people of like, yeah,
there's a bunch of people that ask me to do that. So, so it's okay. But yeah.
Fair, cool.
Uh, I am in no way.
Yeah. I don't, I don't even, I just, I am completely not into it.
You.
Didn't get a little wet, like not even a little bit while she was wet,
probably from the alcohol, she was not wet. Wet. Maybe she spill some on her.
I's the saying maybe, but no. Trying to find off you were into it.
Maybe you're drunk. I was like, I want to do this. Over's saying it's not her.
Thing's not everything. So she didn't get a bit of no, she's saying no, so no.
Okay. This is a confession we're gonna make to guys. All right. Uh,
I know about Doja from a different context.
Me and preacher are both street dancers. Okay. Uh, from the city of Montreal.
Well, he's from the city of Montreal. I live here now and uh, she,
she battle a couple. She used to, she, she battled a couple of her homies. Yeah.
Yeah. And the street dance battle. It was pretty crazy to watch. Um, uh,
we thought her team lost, but uh, they ended up getting the w that's story.
That's why we did this video. That's why we did the original event.
We like yo re reparation. Yeah. You stole that win. We gonna still win from you.
But I'm just playing that being said, shout out to her for, for,
for street dance. I always like seeing street dances thrive after their,
their street dance stint. But I just wanted to make that little side note.
I didn't include in the last video, but I wanted to mention.
This time. I, I had a video of me, um, talking about my hair.
Um, I have a lot of, of trouble taking care of my hair.
Um, if I think that it's difficult,
if I feel that it's difficult to take care of my hair, I'm gonna state it.
It doesn't in, in no way.
Doesn't mean that I hate my hair.
My hair is amazing. I have beautiful hair.
I get lots of compliments on it. It's an outer thing. And it's an inner thing.
I know that I'm beautiful. I love myself.
That's why I parade myself on social media constantly.
Why do you think I'm on here all the time? All right.
Well, cuz you, it's not because you love yourself to that.
You're on social media.
Oftentimes people go on social media for validation purposes,
but it's not because you're on social media, loving yourself.
You live yourself the way you are right now.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> that you don't hate a part of you.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> meaning self hate. That being said,
I'm not saying that's what you're doing. Yeah. But it's not.
I'm just saying your argument. I understand it.
But it doesn't mean what you're saying.
It means at the same time in her defense,
it's hard to prove that you don't hate yourself. Its hard to prove a negative.
I cannot. Yeah. I can like something that does not exist.
I'm not saying that she's wrong. Yeah. I'm but her argument,
I understand your argument, but it's bad. It's it's not a good.
Argument. The times that maybe there was a, there was a photo that was,
uh, lightened to a certain point. That just happens.
I'm not behind editing my photos.
This is a whole team of people who are behind editing.
You can speak to them. Not.
Me. I don't mind that you had lightened photos.
I don't like the idea that you put the accountability of how your product looks
on other people. Yes. Other people are part of the process and yes,
other people, it's still your name and it's still your face.
And one thing you're gonna learn in this business is that anything that has your
name in your face, you can throw a blame on your photographer.
You can throw the blame on your lyricist or whoever wrote it at the end of the
day, you're still the face of whatever you say and project.
And so therefore you bear the responsibility of that.
Even if it's not necessarily reflective of your views.
A good business practice is to understand that you hire the right people and you
take accountability for all those things.
So I made a song, I think it was 2015,
but that's irrelevant. Um,
and it has a very offensive term in it.
Um, and it shouldn't be used, period. Uh,
I'm gonna start with,
I'm very sorry to anybody who's taken offense to anybody
who's to anybody who's, who I've hurt, who I have hurt, uh,
using this term. Um, when I used it,
it was because I was in chat rooms all the time and I was
kind of locked away and I was all always on there.
Just dealing with people coming at me left and right.
Talking about different slanderous terms after another,
the term that I used in the song, uh, is one that I learned that day.
So people were calling me at left and right left and right <affirmative> and I
used it in a song and it was to kind of
take back and, and just say,
you to those people.
Okay. I, I, I, I think I get what she's getting at and I,
and I know what she's talking about because I used to be part of a lot of forms.
And so I would see that term before, um,
now the forms weren't necessarily
supremacist forms. That being said,
there was definitely some elements of like extreme right wing on that form.
I'll give you an example. I was part of a form called bodybuilding.com.
You familiar with that? No. Okay. It's a very popular form back in the day.
It was the spot. I'm talking about some of the best stories, right? Oh yeah.
Yeah. The specific spot called the misc is for a bunch of degenerates. Great.
The misc MIS yeah. The miscellaneous section. Right. And let me tell you,
it was very miscellaneous. You'll find anything, anything. Okay.
But also a lot of people saying stuff like didn't do nothing. So, um,
I can imagine that she would've heard that and try to turn to a track.
And it's part of the reason why I think we didn't go in depth on it.
I didn't think it was a great point to hold against her. Uh,
when people were coming for her, I was like, I don't,
I don't agree with that notion. But anyway,
what we did was reporting what Peter people said. Cause like the reason why,
like what, when we mentioned that song, we, I, I believe we said,
it's not that one thing is a glamoration sure aeration of a lot of
things. The, it was that song.
It was distance said that when we brought the song,
it was really to explain how people perceive that. Sure.
People can perceive it the other way. Yeah. And say she is,
but we have no way of knowing.
So you can choose to give her the benefit of that. Or you could choose to,
all we have right now is her award. I, I can't, I can't dictate to somebody,
their intent, cuz I don't know. You can look at their behavior and infer things,
but we don't actually know. So I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna just, I agree.
But when we.
The chat room that I go to is a public chat room. It's uh,
me, my friends, you go in there, there are
<inaudible> people who come in and out of the chat they're they're there. They,
they happen.
And then they're banned the narrative that it's a
white supremacist chat is completely incorrect.
Okay. I, I, I think I know what she's going, but I'm gonna just to,
we didn't cover this point in the original video because we didn't know the idea
that tiny chat was, uh, this person I'm like, no. Okay.
It's just like any other platform you go on YouTube.
You're gonna fight all kinds of channels. Trust me, lengthy videos. Right?
All about that kind of ideology.
Doesn't make the doesn't mean that the platform is necessarily that in that same
token, same thing for Facebook,
we've seen common sections doesn't mean that the whole of Facebook is that in
that same token, tiny chat. Isn't that? And I know this because again,
I mentioned the form I was on the form had some of that,
but it wasn't the whole website and it certainly wasn't the whole form.
So it's important not to, to,
to disparage a platform in order to make a false point.
It's it doesn't work in your favor. I remember when I heard the tiny chat thing,
I'm like, I've used tiny chat before. It's nothing like that,
but it is true that some people come troll, same thing with Twitch.
Any other platform, you'll find people saying the most za things there.
So to her credit, I will admit this is also true.
Look like I said, if we up, we retract it.
I'm fine with doing that rule right now. I will say my bad.
I got the wrong take. Mm-hmm <affirmative> that being said,
it really doesn't absolve you,
the criticism that you're receiving and it doesn't absolve people of the idea
that you may have some internalized issues that being said,
I don't like playing armchair. I tell you got the degree.
I saw so many people being like her dad's been absent. So that's why like,
listen guys, we don't know how that trauma or how that absence affected her.
I'm not going to do that to that person.
That being said based off what you said, which is,
and you saying you were drunk. I would still my, my personal thing.
Look at why you engage in that behavior.
Because to me that is indicative of something. Not sure what,
cuz I don't know. You I'm just saying it is something that's all,
you don't have the credentials to know what it is. No,
but we will be the first to say we were wrong on the race. Play.
You say you lying to that. I will take your word for it. I apologize.
And that's it. I was your best exit. It really was. Honestly,
if you need a publicist holler at me, I won't listen to your music.
But if you pay me enough, I'll come up with the best. Excuse you. <laugh> okay.
Much love, hope this passes for you.
I'm not advocating for you being canceled nor did we in the previous video.
But we never had no, I'm not. I'm not, I'm not a cancel.
If you guys want to cancel, that's your case for your business.
I'm not gonna tell people who they should or shouldn't listen to that being
said, I can't cancel someone I never listened to, but I wouldn't.
Even if I did. So that's my whole point. Anything you want to add to say to her?
Yeah. What we did was what we did. What Abba did,
was try to see where you were coming from and give you an alibi.
What I did was try to see, I tried to look at the perception of the people,
like what they were gonna say and how they weren't gonna think and all that.
So yeah. Whatever do you girl, do you, yeah, again, just avoid,
avoid ERs, right? Even if you get injured, <laugh> okay. Even if your,
your legs are broken, just avoid any ERs. And here's the other thing also, look,
I know there's a lot of true rolling,
involved with like a lot of stuff and you know, that's fine,
but also recognize that sometimes always engaging in that.
Sometimes you may also take it too far. Is that one of those instances? No,
listen, of course we can take it too far. I mean, we are when we do jokes.
Yeah. There's plenty of jokes that I've done. I taken too far. Really?
Of course. I don't feel that way. That I
to be the. Let me, let me get the Purell out. See yo,
no recording. Calm down. No recording. You know why?
Because you can't put hand sanitizer on feet. My, you need fleet sanitizer.
If you got it here <laugh>
if you don't grab your and get the out. No, but seriously. Hold on.
Yeah, go ahead. Uh, what was I saying? What was I, yeah, yeah.
There's plenty of there's plenty of times where I've done jokes where I went too
far. It, it like it happens or situation where you push it too far. It,
it happens. I gotta put one thing, your apologies. You did right there.
I gotta give you that was some of the best apology that I've seen.
Cause off not the best, but that I've seen from other people when,
when people up the apologies, I like, okay,
like I did that and I did that and everything and stuff and I heard people,
but the reason why is, and then he give you a bigger, like,
she just really tried to set the record straight. I was like, listen.
She said she up. Yeah. She said, she said, yo, I was dumb.
So that's and I've like,
I've always said that that's the kind of apology that I like that I,
like you said, you like sort apology. I up I'm walking away. Yes, yes, yes.
But that, that that's, that would be the perfect, you know, I up,
I also understand like if people misrepresent. Yes, exactly.
So she has to that's what I'm saying.
So to me it was still a short apology because she have to set the records
straight about to say,
she's not trying to make her look like the victim of something. Right. Right.
Which is fine. I'm not, I'm not still not a fan. Yeah. But I, I agree.
Here's why I was sick. I thought that apology. And then she wants a better one.
She needs to hire me. <laugh>.